the ps4 slim and the ps4 pro have been
officially unveiled but they're not the
only pieces of hardware getting a new
look I'm Tony and this is your upgraded
GameSpot news update first up is the new
controller it's got a front-facing light
bar and USB communication support but
since these aren't massive improvements
it's keeping the DualShock for name
it'll cost you 60 bucks and will launch
in black red and blue color schemes the
PlayStation camera also got a makeover
and now has a cylindrical design
it'll cost $60 as well the new $25
vertical stands connects with the slim
and pro models finally sony is putting
out a new headset the high-end 160
dollar platinum wireless headset
supports 7.1 surround sound contains a
hidden microphone and is meant to work
perfectly with PlayStation VR it's
coming this holiday season the ps4 pro
launches November 10th and the new
standard slim model will be available
starting next week on Thursday September
15 if you decide to pick one up you'll
have plenty of new accessories to choose
from and to keep up with all the latest
playstation news you're already in the
right place
you